fallout 4 mods on ps4 were slated to
launch back in June but support still
isn't available that certainly doesn't
bode well for mod support for Skyrim
special edition either Bethesda hinted
earlier that this delay was Sony's fault
but now they're full-on pointing fingers
in a blog post Bethesda stated after
months of discussion with Sony we regret
to say that while we have long been
ready to offer mod support on
PlayStation 4 sony has informed us that
they will not approve user mods the way
they should work where users can do
anything they want for either fallout 4
or Skyrim special edition until Sony
will allow us to offer proper mod
support that content will not be
available mod support has been available
on xbox one since May and on PC even
earlier than that at this point it seems
like it may never come to ps4 unless
Sony changes its mind newco world may be
the last time vault dwellers get new
fallout 4 content on ps4 keep an eye on
gamespot as the story develops and for
all the biggest Bethesda news you're
already in the right place
you